[Music]
you know i was thinking doesn't
analytics kind of reveal at some point
you got to beat the odds it's hard to
believe the writers have had one winning
season
now in the last 19 because this year is
about over regardless of what happened
sunday in denver
the best the raiders could do is eight
and eight on the season if they do get a
win sunday at least it'll be a one game
improvement over last year
but don't you almost feel for derek carr
the quarterback he's been on this team
the longest so he's gone the longest
without a postseason game
even in 2016 when the raiders made the
postseason he was hurt and couldn't play
this was supposed to be their year the
nfl added a team an extra team to the
postseason mix and
many felt this is the best raiders team
in a while but now they'll go into the
final game
of the season with a disappointed
derrick i thought he
he he responded to a lot of different
things he threw the ball
great threw the ball down the field
accurately
and had a great scrambled bomb to
aguilar to put us ahead then he brought
us down the field again to win the game
so
no derek will start finish the season
just
like we had anticipated he would and
whether marcus has a role in this we'll
wait and see all right this will be an
interesting off-season not only to watch
the players who's going to be around
next year
but who are they going to hire to be
that defensive coordinator
hey we'd like to invite you to watch our
season finale of raiders pregame live
this sunday at 8 o'clock
we'll prepare you for the raiders season
finale share some thoughts on
who really made a difference on the team
this year and much much more coming up
sunday morning
right here on channel 8. boy what a
privilege it is to play in the national
football league
most of the players know that some you
have to question but not texans jj watt
he was asked about their losing season
being eliminated from the postseason
and there's really nothing to play for
so why go out and bust your tail well
here's a portion of his response we're
professional athletes getting paid a
whole lot of money if you can't come in
and put work in in the building go out
to the practice field and work hard do
your lifts and do what you're supposed
to do
you should not be here this is a job
we are getting paid a whole lot of money
there are a lot of people that
watch us and invest their time and their
money into buying our jerseys and buying
a whole bunch
and they care about it they care every
single week we're in week 16
and work 4 and 11 and there's fans that
watch this game that show up to the
stadium
that put in time and energy and effort
and care about this
so if you can't go out there and you
can't work out you can't show up on time
you can't practice you can't want to go
out there and win you shouldn't be here
because this is a privilege it's the
greatest job in the world you get to go
out and play a game
oh so true another guy who looks at
playing football as a privilege as unlv
running back charles williams he's the
best player on the team
and he announced he's coming back for
another season now because of covid
the ncaa is allowing seniors to make a
choice and unlv
fans got to be thrilled with this
decision not only is williams best
player on the rebel roster as one of the
best players in the mountain west
so you know this news is music to the
ears of coach
marcus arroyo boy there are a ton of
knights fans in the city that can't wait
for january 14th to get here
that's when the knights face off against
the ducks in the 2021 season opener
vegas's quest for the cup begins at home
with the start of a 56 game schedule
that has the two favorites to win the
cup in the same division
remember there are four divisions with
each team playing only the teams in that
division
until the postseason final four so
colorado the odds-on favorite to win the
cup at 6-1 then vegas next at 9-1
while the defending champion lightning
are 15 to 2.
i know i speak for a lot of fans in this
city when i say let the games
begin hey if you haven't heard from the
runner rebels program there's a reason
for that they've been dealing with covet
isolation
the team hasn't been able to gather for
a full practice in a few weeks now but
they're close
on monday january 4th the team will be
back into full practice
then they're scheduled to play their
first games at colorado state a week
from tomorrow night remember coach otts
revealed that he came down with covid
had the mild symptoms since
recovered so that's good news denise
thanks chris i think
um is it j.j water t.j watt j.j watt
i i like him he's my new favorite player
next season great bites
yes i like that so true yes all right
still ahead